what are the obstacles to a broadened
palette of school choice opportunities
it's special interest groups it's the
education unions that have been around
forever benefiting from the status quo
and it's not students that are
benefiting it's adults and it's been
that way for the past few decades what
about you know who are the other groups
that are against increased school choice
because parents I mean parents with
school-aged children K through 12 even
you know most of them you know come back
with like 85 or 90 percent or higher
belief that there's their children
schools or somewhat are very good so are
they part of the problem so we know that
parents do tend to overestimate how well
their child's school performs so what we
need to do is show parents that school
choice benefits everyone that it's
beneficial to them to have options for
instance online learning is a great
example of this that perhaps your
child's school is a great school but
perhaps your child's school doesn't
offer a Mandarin Chinese look what could
be available if you had the ability to
choose from online options as well